θα είναι και ποψήσες τις βολευτικές ναι και θα εδεν ξερω θα είναι αλλά αν
θα μεταφραστίς ει ψήφους ίναι το ερώτια είδαμην και σε άλλες περιπτώσεις σίγουρα τα λάειξ
δεν είναι ψήφι όπως για να πάω λίγο όή παρα πολλά χρόνια πριν τηλεθαίαση δεν
ήταν ψηφι διανθρώποι η οποίι γράφαν πάρα πολύ καλά νούμερα στην τηλεώρα συνηστες ερχοπές τους
ις τα αδέλτεία ι σιότι δίποται και όχει μονο στην κύπροη κες το εξωτερικό όταν
εμπήκασε ψηφοτέλτεια ενπι αγκαλάνε όπως και άλλοι λουκά φουρλάς για παραδήγμα επιεν πάρα πολλά καρα
δεν υπάρχει μία φόρμουλα την οποία λέεις μάλιστατούδος οθυσέας έχει πάρα πολούς φόλου ε τις
τοίς τα γραμβάλτο στο ψηχοτέλιο και να βας τοσφέρει τους ψήβους εντε τόσο να πλογϊκά
ταπράμακαι βλέπουμε ότι από τους συ λόγους στη κατί ντοενήντα από τις τηλεοράσεις τι εκπομπές
του διώχι γιάδες πλέουν βλέπμο ήταν πάντα γίνονται στασόσολμύτα τα πάνταόπως βέσιας ι βιτεάκαι φωτογραφίας
ξτρατίες τα πάντα είναι όμως έτσι θησεαδηλαδή για να βγάλεις μια φωτογραφία κάπου έχεις πάρει
α κάποιους ανθρώπους έχεις δει με κάποιους ανθρώπους έχεις μιλήσει σε μία γκοινωνία του μεγέθου
στις κύπρου που είναι πολύ μικρι και εύκολα μεταφέρονται πληροφορίες εντυπώσεις ν γα παραδείγμα νοθυσέας
παει σε ένα χωριό της λέμεσού στο καφενε ως ν ανειστιατόριο έχει το φωτογράφον του
βγάλετες φωτογραφίες του αναρτίσεητες αλλά εη συμπεριφορά του το εστιατόριο δεν ήταν κάλει ήτανν αγενείς
ήταν αλλαζώνας χιλιαδιό μάθεολιθα το μάθει όλι κύπρος η νόουτα που λέμε και θα τομάθηκε
με πολύ χειροτροτο τα κακάνέα α τους βάζουμε και λίκτάλσαν και αποστόμας εστόμα μεγελθύνεται άρα
ενα ένα πράμα το ισταγραμ αλλά τα υτώ χρονα υπάρχει και οι προσωπική επαφί